busted murders we've taken down cartels
but today we Face the worst New York has
to offer the Fire Department
fire marshal boom We Meet Again
detective Peralta who flies down and
made you look I didn't look and I'm
wearing shorts there is no fly that's
not what your mom said you make no sense
and now I'm inside your head prepare to
die
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and he runs it in I I'd like to see you
score one good because you're about to
see it you're about to see it straight
to hell
[Music]
[Music]
I know
I can't believe Sal's is gone this place
is an institution it's the best pizza in
the neighborhood
eighth best
yeah a tragedy I mean any food related
crime is a tragedy
oh no Heads Up Fire Marshall
foreign
Rod doing here
hey Peralta hey Boone what are you doing
here you Nimrod uh there was a fire big
question is what are you doing here what
did somebody call in a missing donut uh
actually someone reported they couldn't
find your head but we found it it was up
your butt you're a fireman you should
know how to treat that burn joke's on
you because this is a fire which means
it is fire department jurisdiction so
why don't you back off and let New
York's bravest handle it you know they
only call you that because New York's
best it's spraying stuff with water is
too wordy oh well it's too bad we all
can't be as awesome as New York's finest
which by the way sounds like my mom
describing her dishware which and and
she's dead so let's tread lightly on the
response that's not fair yeah well look
we heard this might be arson so we
wanted to check it out no I'm not
letting you onto my crime scene okay
all right fine you know what you're not
invited to our next murder
hot moving we gotta distract them tell
them your little boy's cat got stuck up
in a tree oh undercover work I love it I
need more backstory first off can it be
my daughter's cat okay but if you get
made because of that it's on you fine
let's talk about the cat short hair long
hair tabby short hair Calico the sun has
adopted your wife is in a coma oh that's
brutal I like it thank you
hey guys
guys I I really need your help my little
boy Brian my angel I bought him a
short-haired Calico after my wife fell
into a coma motorcycle crash and now the
cat's stuck in a tree
handsome little guy uh hey just got
locked out so he doesn't care
Brian was adopted to his abandonment
issues just struck out a t-ball last
week everyone called him crying Brian
hello Peralta
you looking for something what is the
deal with you in this second-rate pizza
joint this place is a Brooklyn
institution and I'm here because you
think Sal did it and you're wrong he did
do it Sal is in financial trouble he has
no alibi and in cases of arson the owner
always did it what's going on sir what's
going on is it Peralta his screw with me
for the last time and now he's gonna pay
oh you know what Boone anytime you want
to give
ah
you're getting nervous Jake you're
getting nervous yet
[Music]
marshmallow
I'll tell my guys what to do don't tell
me what to tell people what to do well
make me not do it tough guy
I apologize Marshall Boone for detective
Peralta's actions something I find
myself doing quite frequently in my
defense I was the only one saying we
should stop hitting
hitting them kicking them will hurt more
okay I'm a reasonable man so I'm just
gonna say this
for all to immediate
immediate jurisdiction and he's obsessed
with this pizza place and what I'm
obsessed with is how you're bungling
this investigation oh they should write
a song about it called Welcome to the
bungle
seriously why are you dragging Sal's
pizzas through the mud that place is
special why is it special because it's
the best pizza in the neighborhood well
according to Charles's email blast it's
actually number eight Captain reads my
blast of course it's the only one that
measures mouthfeel are you kidding right
now this isn't about pizza what's it
actually about
when I was a kid I was shortstopped by
my little league team oh my God the
truth it's not a brag
my dad was the coach and after every
game he would take the team to Sal's
halfway through our last season he left
me and my mom and the worst part about
it was that I couldn't go with him to
Sal's anymore
well that's certainly not what I
expected this to be about
I'm sorry
I'm sorry that happened to you I mean
what kind of dad does Lisa's son like
that
look you're you're a cop and and I'm a
firefighter but underneath all of it
we're just two boys whose dance
abandoned them and you and I we're gonna
solve this thing together okay okay okay
but first let's hug like man this is
happening
here
they're there
there it's there I'm coming in no boil
oh nothing better after a long shift
than coming to Shaw's it's like cheers
where everybody knows your name plus
where everybody knows your name is hell
you're describing help guys guys guys
are those firefighters hey what's going
on why is the FDNY in our cop bar we
needed a new place since our bar
O'Brien's burned out you couldn't put
that out you probably started it most
arsonists turned out to be firefighters
it's not true though it is very common
and definitely what happened in this
case I'm surprised you guys even want to
come here since you have to take the
stairs I know how much you like sliding
on poles we don't like sliding on poles
we do it to save lives it's dangerous
you can ask my best friend Steve oh no
wait you can't actually because he's
dead tripped through a pole hole broke
his neck that's horrible sorry but this
is a firefighter bar now although we
might want to make some changes to the
decor I'm thinking some old-timey
pressure gauges maybe an autographed
photo of Dennis Leary from Rescue Me You
wouldn't I check it out you son of a
[ __ ] Hank you gotta get rid of these
hose humpers it's number us look guys I
don't want to take science I just want
to make money then keep it a cup bar we
drink like crazy yeah because of all the
tragedy we experience on a daily basis
son oh yeah we experienced plenty of
tragedy too we lose a man a year to the
pole hole how about this if it's about
money let's just have a drink off
whoever racks up the biggest tab by
closing time gets to keep shots okay
defectives
ah my guys can handle that oh can they
because the 99 is about to bring the
real heat get ready for the background
[ __ ]
four hours left I'm done 58 Amy where
are you at four drinks what's four
drinking me again why don't you come
over here and find out right horny Amy
feels like you should retire that one
for the metoo era why don't you come
over here and make me all right there's
only one thing left to do drink faster
it's got a bunch of fires throughout the
city mine's better no
we can do this things seem Bleak now but
the night is always darkest before the
dawn this is Shaw's we've had weddings
here
funerals Shahs is part of our family
because that is what we are
a family and we're not just Amy and Rosa
and Hitchcock and school
hope we're losing yeah anyway bye bye
what am I doing calling him he doesn't
care about us or what we want when I
heard that I was shaken to my core I
thought this bar was beneath me but what
was actually beneath me was my own
behavior I turned my back out we do not
have time for this just drink your
drinking Hank bring me a charbonne
damn sure you took that Chardonnay to
the house how you feeling let me take
stock my equilibrium is Askew my vision
is partially impaired and I'm clearly
slurring my words to put a fine point on
it your boy's turned well well well
there's only a minute left and you are
six bucks down I don't think you guys
are gonna make it hang another job this
one's hot it was sitting on the radiator
she's never gonna make it yes he will
just don't breathe let the liquid into
your lungs
five four three two Closing Time cops
win
[Applause]
all right fine
the bar is yours but
we're keeping this come on before we all
go home and pass out I want to say how
sorry I am that I deserted you earlier I
want you to know that I care about you
all so very much each and every one of
you Boyle Santiago Diaz Hitchcock
oh